m
dom
qu'avez-vous
il
pas du tout
ici c'est une pièce très importante dans
les futures maisons dans les maisons de
vivront peut-être dans dix ans puisque
c'est la pièce dans laquelle se trouve
réuni tous les moyens de communication
c'est une pièce importante on y trouve
tous les appareils traditionnels que
nous connaissons déjà à savoir le
téléviseur la radio l'électrophone le
magnétophone mais on y trouve également
des engins que nous ne connaîtrons pour
nous en europe que d'ici quelques dix
ans à savoir les vidéocassettes on
trouve également un ordinateur et toutes
sortes de choses très importantes
quant au camp les sociologues parlent
des années 80 et de la façon dont nous
vivrons à cette époque là par conséquent
ici il y a énormément de gadgets mais il
ne s'agit pourtant pas de science
fiction tout simplement
il s'agit d'une oeuvre bâti à partir
d'une constatation les matières
plastiques seront utilisés de façon de
plus en plus importante au cours des
prochaines années dans le bâtiment et
dans la décoration et d'ici quelques
années le prix du bois risque
d'augmenter dans des proportions
considérables et celui des matières
plastiques de baisser en raison même de
l'augmentation de leur consommation
alors il faut trouver des solutions de
remplacement adapté à la vie des gens
telle qu'elle est prévue cette vie des
gens courent 1981 à ludwigshafen on fait
en ce moment des études davantage de
celle qu'on vient de faire c'est qu'elle
a mis en concurrence de deux équipes de
chercheurs dans chacune de ces équipes
on trouve des sociologues des
psychologues des décorateurs des
architectes des spécialistes de l'ide
statique industriels sont les gens qu'on
appelle assez communément des designers
tout ce monde-là a réfléchi et a produit
des maquettes et vous pouvez voir autour
de nous le résultat si les prédictions
de ces gens là se réalisent les
appartements de 1981 ressembleront à
celui ci ce sera un cadre de vie
beaucoup plus moderne beaucoup plus
souple que celui que nous connaissons en
ce moment est de plus toutes les
habitudes de vie que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui risque de s'en trouver
profondément modifié